meine damen und herren wir gehen jetzt
direkt rüber live nach österreich denn
dort hat die regierung verkündet dass es
einen lock down für das ganze land ab
montag geben würde alexander
schallenberg der bundeskanzler spricht
das ist möglich sein muss muss menschen
in österreich zu überzeugen zu
überzeugen dass sie sich freiwillig
impfen lassen zu überzeugen dass dies zu
ihrem eigenen schutz und zum schutz
wieder mit menschen ihre liebenden ihrer
freunde und arbeitskollegen tun
aber
wir haben wir müssen den realitäten
einfach ins auge schauen wir haben zu
viele politische kräfte auch in diesem
land die ganz vehement und massiv von
öffentlich dagegen ankämpfen das ist
verantwortungslos
das ist eigentlich ein attentat auf
unser gesundheitssystem
und aufgestachelt von diesen radikalen
hilf gegnern von fadenscheinigen fake
news haben sich leider zu viele und
dunst nicht impfen lassen die konsequenz
daraus sind überfüllte intensivstationen
und
enormes menschliches leid und das kann
niemand von uns wollen wir haben uns
heute die gestern zu einem sehr
schwierigen beschluss durchgerungen zum
beschluss dass es sehr rasch jetzt eine
bundesweite impfpflicht in die wege
leiten diese soll bereits am ersten
februar nächsten jahres 2022 gelten
die
impfquote nachhaltig zu erhöhen ich
glaube da sind wir uns alle einig die
impfquote nachhaltig zu erhöhen ist
unser einziger weg um aus diesem
teufelskreis von virus wählen und
lockdown diskussionen endgültig raus zu
kommen wir wollen keine fünfte welle wir
wollen keine sechster und siebter welle
wir wollen diese diskussionen im
nächsten frühjahr und sommer nicht mehr
führen müssen und jahre müssen zur
kenntnis nehmen dass videos geht nicht
weg es bleibt und wir müssen lernen
damit umzugehen und die art und weise
wie damit lernen kann umzugehen ist die
impfung das ist unser hexe ticket das
ist der wesentliche
weltliche
neben dieser mittelfristigen perspektive
bedarf es aber leider auch kurzfristiger
maßnahmen die bundesregierung die
landeshauptleute sind da überein
gekommen dass wir in anbetracht der
ernsten lage in anbetracht des
infektionsgeschehen es keine andere
möglichkeit sehen dass weitere
einschränkende maßnahmen für alle zu
verordnen zum schutz von uns allen zum
schutz unseres gesundheitssystems ab
montag für maximal 20 tage wird ein
bundesweiter lockt an gelten der nach
zehn tagen evaluiert wird er endet
automatisch spätestens am 13 dezember ab
diesem datum ab dem 13 dezember gilt für
geimpfte und genesene kein lok tor mehr
natürlich das sage ich auch gleich dazu
wird es in dieser phase sowie das
vielleicht schon einige vergangenheit
geübt haben
und
sprach von
einem attentat auf das gesundheitssystem
wenn man sich nicht impfen lässt und
wenn man eben als sein corona leugner
auch fake news verbreitet ja erkennbar
hat der bundeskanzler österreichs dort
auch die rechtsnationale fpl im blick da
gibt es ja wirklich die abstrusesten
meinungen bei spd-politikern österreich
war jetzt vor kurzem einen wurm mittel
ausverkauften apotheken weil es das
würde gegen korona beispielsweise
schützen so und hier ist es also völlig
verquer die fpö treibt ja wirklich ein
sehr sehr böses spiel unter anderem zwei
demonstrationen in wien angemeldet zwei
von der fpö an diesem kommenden samstag
gegen korona gegen lockdown maßnahmen
also da muss man schon sagen da ist der
ton den der bundeskanzler schickt
sicherlich übertrieben aber er meint auf
jeden fall die fpd kräfte und die
impfrate in österreich liegt bei etwas
über 60 prozent also nochmal deutlich
unter der auch bei uns in deutschland
das land hat wirklich dramatische
probleme aber die wehrpflicht deshalb
die impfpflicht auch ab februar auch
eine drastische maßnahme die hier so
noch nicht angedacht wird